[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's start there with jay bilas espn
college basketball
analyst um your thoughts on russell
westbrook
going to the lakers i love it i think
it's going to be great to watch
and teaming up with a.d and and lebron
it should be really fun um i mean i
don't differ with anything you're saying
westbrook's gotta kind of live with his
record but
uh he's a gamer man i i we all watched
him in college but i remember ben
halland telling me that
his freshman year sophomore year in high
school he couldn't dunk and then he
you know he was this freak athlete i was
like he couldn't dunk really
he's just an amazing amazing player but
what do you remember about that because
he was
one year at ucla um but do you remember
anything special about him that you
thought would translate to the nba
oh yeah i mean i wasn't sure he's going
to be taking number four overall
but you knew he was a lottery pick and
would be a great player just because of
his incredible
athleticism and i remember him being a
really quiet
um you know quiet young player and
uh but he was he was a thrill to watch
and heck those ucla teams back then they
went to three straight final fours and
he was certainly part of that but they
had a they had a bunch of
great players you know kevin love and
westbrook i mean it was
it was an awesome awesome group to be
around but
jay just froze up so we'll see if we can
uh
get him back yeah because you
you know i remember when uh kevin love
came out and was drafted and paulie and
i were having a discussion oh jay is
back there
uh did you realize kevin love was
something special back then as well jay
for kevin love now yeah back then at
ucla
oh yeah because he could he was like a
crazy rebounder i mean he wasn't in the
kind of physical condition he is now
uh where he's you know really thin and
cut he was a little you know a little
heavier
but i remember being a practice one day
at paulie and the players had left the
floor and i was sitting out with ben
allen and he was telling me that kevin
love could throw a
chest pass from the baseline into the
opposite basket 94 feet i'm going oh
there's no way
and he sent a manager in to bring kevin
out and he made i think he made
seven out of ten and and it was
you know if you and i did that we would
maybe get it to the opposite free-throw
line and he's making buckets
from the i've never i still have never
seen anything like that
you worked the draft last night uh you
certainly love
cade cunningham um what does he do
you didn't you said he didn't have that
freakish athleticism but what is it that
he does so well that makes him so
special
he he really does check you know check
every box that you would have for a
player he doesn't have any weaknesses
um he is i think he's a lot like
you know maybe because it's detroit you
start saying well you know he has
a lot of similarities to grant hill
except at that age
he was um you know kate cunningham's a
far better shooter than grant was i
think he's more skilled and more
polished
but a lot of players are now the players
are way ahead of where they were years
ago
but but the one thing he doesn't have is
that like he's a great athlete but he's
not a
a freak crazy athlete like grant was
that that's the one difference but
uh because of the way you know he shoots
over 40 from three he's got every move
to get his own shot
uh he's a ridiculously good pastor
handler
and he's got you know he's got the
ability to make plays
uh when it counts and he's not only is
he not afraid of it but he kind of gets
what he's supposed to do in those in
those um those moments he and jalen
suggs
uh of gonzaga um who was taken
uh fifth i i think to orlando i think
have similarities there that that you
know end of games they're they're fierce
competitors in addition to being really
good players
when you start to look at the draft
let's say 20 years ago
is evan mobley the first player taken
not 20 years ago because that was uh
that was lebron's year was that
2000. no no that style i mean a big man
let's well let's say in a different oh i
see what you're saying yeah okay i'm
sorry yeah i misunderstood yeah yeah
yeah evan mobley would have been one and
same thing with last year james wiseman
um he would have been one we just
everybody thought differently back then
and the game was different and honestly
dan it took me a while and still taken
me a while to wrap my head around you
know i still kind of lean toward
you know a big guy when you're you're
making some of those
oh he was going to nail that too he's
frozen
ready to say decision
over just you know being really good in
in certain areas
uh but i i've gone away from that too
because smaller guys do really well now
but also i look at the greek freak and i
thought the difference in the nba finals
was he went low
he went down low and nobody could guard
him there whereas they'd had him on the
perimeter
bringing the ball up occasionally
shooting a three
i just i wonder if there's going to be a
team that just says you got to deal with
us and this is how we play and almost be
counter-intuitive to what
you know the new the new nba is all
about can you see a strategy like that
yeah but but i don't think you're gonna
see somebody say okay let's go back to
the way the houston rockets did it in
the 80s and have twin towers and we'll
put them down the low blocks and play
high low
and clog everything up you know now you
have to
that's why i differ with with people
that say that you know the golden state
warriors couldn't hang with the
the you know jordan's bulls or anything
like that
um i i believe they could because the
game's so different it's more spread out
they're more three
shot and uh and i think spreading out
those d
and then you start asking okay who would
who would bill cartwright have guarded
uh you know there there are a lot of
questions that would have to be answered
and it's not a no-brainer that this team
would win
just because players were tougher back
then and they were better
competitors and all that you know they
act like nobody called fouls back then
it's just flagrant fouls were allowed
and
and
you know like oh my god they are these
skinny skinny guys couldn't have made it
as if george gervin and reggie miller
didn't play and
remember steve kerr played in those
games too you know he kind of laughs at
this stuff too about
you know today's player not being able
to hang back in the day but who do you
think would be more shocked if jordan's
bowls
were facing the warriors but they had no
idea that style the warriors played
or the warriors would be playing
jordan's bowls
in the style that they play or the
physicality who would have the harder
time
kind of adjusting to what they're seeing
what they're what they're experiencing
well i i mean i think the bulls that
have a little bit of a harder time
because of
of the amount of threes that we're being
shot and how spread out everything is
and the movement
uh that you see now and the there's more
passing than than back in the day
um so i think it look they'd both be
shocked in a way it depends
who's roughing the game by the way
they're going by the old rules of the
new rules
um you know when you could you could
flagrant foul i don't know if you saw
this but it's kind of funny there's
something on social media the other day
about the the opening of the nfl today
back when brent mussberger and irv cross
and phyllis george run it and somebody
had said that
everything they showed in there is now
illegal in football
like the the stuff that you know the all
the highlights they showed
illegal and uh so every game has changed
and they've just taken
you know like basketball's just taken
out flagrant they they you know
the stuff that caused fights they
haven't taken out you know fouls they
they still called fouls back in the day
uh i'll leave you with this this the
state of college basketball with what's
happening in football
how is that going to impact college
basketball
we froze up again
we'll leave that question there you
yeah you froze up here so uh i'm sorry
yeah how do what do you think is going
to happen with college basketball
well it's going to remain healthy as
long as the ncaa tournament does but i
think we're going to see the big shots
play the big shots more often
and we're not going to see as many you
know intersectional games against
directional schools just like we're
seeing in football
but basketball is going to follow what
football does
and and you're going to see
consolidation of power among the big
conferences in football
and the the the big are going to get
bigger and more powerful
because the ncaa is not going to be
policing it anymore and so the
conferences are going to be making all
the decisions and their decisions are
going to be how much money can we make
and they're going to make it i mean the
sec is gonna be making
over a billion dollars a year very very
soon
and uh and everybody else is gonna have
to scramble to keep up
and they're going to do it like they're
gonna do whatever it takes to keep up
jay have a great weekend fun watch last
night thank you uh as always for uh
joining us
great being with you thanks for having
me that's jay bilas espn college
basketball
analyst